end of the war when we pulled out of
vietnam two and a half
million people were killed there's
people trying to cling to helicopters to
hold on to their lives
and i saw that and i was shocked because
they showed me what communism was
the winner is john boyce
[Applause]
[Music]
four-time oscar nominee winner of one of
those 11 time golden globe nominee with
four wins
star of mission impossible heat
deliverance coming home midnight cowboy
and so many other classic movies jon
voight is no question one of the
hollywood greats
an iconic actor wide acclaim tons of
memorable characters
and he happens to be one of the most
outspoken conservatives and trump
supporters
in all of the entertainment industry but
that wasn't always the case
as he was finding prominence in movies
in the late 60s and early 70s
john found himself echoing the beliefs
held by the majority of the liberal
hollywood circle
in particular he was actively marching
and speaking out against the vietnam war
as a young man with newfound cloud
make love not war that's a message
nearly anybody could get behind
but something changed as john began to
see the marxist intentions behind the
anti-war activism
john began to realize he didn't stand
for the things hollywood was by and
large selling
in our show we'll get into how in 2020
we're living through another marxist
movement infiltrating american thought
and society
one very similar to what john
experienced firsthand in the 70s
plus john tells us about his big break
that launched him into the hollywood
limelight
his advice for conservatives trying to
make it in tinsel town and his thoughts
on the new woke academy award
[Music]
stipulations
hey hey and welcome this is the ben
shapiro show sunday special just a
reminder
we'll be doing some bonus questions at
the end with john the only way to get
access to that part of the conversation
is to become a member
head on over to dailywire.com become a
member you'll have access to all of the
full conversations with every one
of our awesome guests john voigt thanks
so much for showing up really appreciate
oh
this is amazing i'm just even watching
you do that is an amazing thing i come
you know i'm uh i'm i'm
very excited to be with you if that
excited you get
get ready because this is going to blow
your mind
so let's start with uh with some
hollywood questions because
uh we'll get to politics alone let me
ask you a question do you change your
personality when you do this show
i don't think so i might be a little bit
less uh wild than i am normally
maybe less wild yeah holy smokes i know
i i'm basically dead when i do this show
but yeah well you're fantastic you turn
something on
uh when you when i hear you know when i
hear action you know i usually calm down
you know i don't go oh yeah i don't go
with the same steam that the director
has when he says action you know that's
because you're a good i just
whereas i am a terrible terrible actress
so for me i act like a squirrel on
ritalin in any case
let's talk about how you got into acting
in the first place because everybody
sort of has a different story as to how
they got into
that particular area of the industry how
did you get into that yeah well
i i when i was a little kid i i'm three
years old and you have three
kids i was i started
painting and drawing when i was three
and i and that was my that was my
whole focus i loved it you know i had
papers all over the house my parents
were very tolerant of
all of you had to walk over these
paintings and drawings
and i did that for a couple years and
then i saw
uh movies with my father and my two
brothers
i was the middle of three three boys a
year apart
and we saw movies and that was when i
was five
and when i was six uh i retired from
painting and drawing because i realized
this
new media was uh
made made my stuff a dimensional art
obsolete
in my mind right and i really when i say
retired i had the
sadness of it you know didn't an
emptiness
in a way and i kept drawing and
doing things for people's favors and
stuff for school and all of that but uh
but i
i'd lost my real connection and i didn't
think that i would ever be part of this
this world of film uh but i was a fun
kid you know i was all playful i liked
making people laugh and i
i followed my dad's lead he was a golf
professional
and he loved uh he had a wonderful sense
of humor and he
loved sid caesar
you know different things that he
focused on and i
fell in love with sid caesar's work and
imogen coca and
you know carl reiner and those guys and
uh
and i used to imitate sid's characters
at school
and i got attention for it you know
enough that they asked me to do the
comedy lead in the show
in the sixth grade and i
took it very seriously and looking back
i did a lot of sophisticated things
at that time that would have indicated
that i would have gone on but i
i was playing golf because my dad had
taught me golf
i loved all athletics and i loved
horsing around
and had a lot of fun you know and i
didn't take anything too seriously
then in high school again and then in
college
i every year of college the first three
years of college
i was always asking mostly gals
what do you think i should do when i get
out of college and in college i was uh
i was very active in in
i was taking art because i knew i could
get through it and i was very i was the
president of the
class president of the fraternity that
i'm very active writing things for the
newspaper i was
walking through campus when i came back
just before my senior year
and i looked at the book that i had in
my hand
and it was a book of criticism of
of acting of the british act of the
great british actors
by kenneth tynan and his all these
reviews and i had marked
all of lawrence olivier's
heroic roles and ken steiner loved him
so he's very romantic about
lawrence olivier and described
everything that he did and i understood
what olivier was doing
in creating those roles how he uh
illuminated things in this in
in the story by the way he chose to do
the roles
character acting you know and i looked
at it and i said to myself and i
actually said it
i think even even verbally i said i know
what i
want to do i want to be him
i want to be him lawrence olivia
and i was a i was a yeah you know i
looked very young when i was young
blonde hair and uh tall thin fella
and i knew i wasn't going to be mature
for a while
to do certain kinds of roles but i knew
i was going to from that moment i knew i
was going to go to new york
and start school all over again trying
to learn learn a few things
and get into acting and i knew at that
moment that i wasn't going to quit
i was going to stay with it it's funny
things that you remember you know
and sure enough i had my ups and downs
but
i was very fortunate to have the career
i have
so i want to ask you how the big break
happened where you went from being
a guy in college you wanted to act to
you know being an oscar winner and
multiple oscar nominee
and all this i'm going to ask you about
that in just one second but first let's
talk about stamps
right now is a terrible time to go to
the post office as we slowly adjust to
this new normal
we still need to be smart about how we
do business luckily there's stamps.com
to make things easier
thousands of small business owners have
discovered the benefits of stamps.com in
recent months they've been able to keep
their businesses running and avoid the
crowds of the post office all from their
home computers or office computers with
stamps.com
it can print postage on demand and avoid
going to the post office at all
you'll save money with discounted rates
you can't even get at the post office
stamps.com also offers ups services with
discounts up to 62
no residential surcharges here at the
daily wire we've been using stamps.com
since 2017 which is why we are a
thriving
media empire no more wasting our time or
our money
stamps.com brings all the mailing and
shipping services you need directly to
your computer in the comfort of your
home or office
whether you're a small business sending
invoices or an online seller shipping
out products
or you're just working from home and you
need to mail stuff stamps.com can handle
it all with ease
simply use your computer to print
official us postage 24 7 for any letter
any package any class mail anywhere you
want to send it once the mail is ready
leave it for the mail carrier schedule a
pickup drop it in the mailbox
it is indeed that simple again there are
great discounts five cents off every
stamp up to 62 percent
off those usps and ups shipping rates
right now my listeners get a special
offer it includes a four week trial plus
free postage and
digital scale no long-term commitment
just go to stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage type in shapiro that's
stamps.com
enter shapiro okay so you decide that uh
acting is what you want to do when you
go to new york a lot of people end up
going to new york thinking that this is
what they're going to do and then
you know washing dishes three years
later so how does the big break happen
where you don't end up washing dishes in
new york
well i did a little stuff to earn a
living uh you know
trying to help my dad out i wasn't very
good at it i had to lean on my father a
lot
uh but i went to sky
i was fortunate enough to go to
gain entrance into sandy meisner's
professional class
and in that i learned some basics
i i i was very unsure because i had gone
to a
rather bad teacher prior
who was full of himself and didn't
really know what he was talking about
and i was but you know teachers have so
much control over
over their students and you know you're
glued to every word and then i realized
this guy wasn't taking me anywhere and
and i found my way to sandy meisner and
sandy gave me a
structure that i really deeply needed
and i spent two years
going to every class twice a week
and at the end of that time i came out
thinking
now i have to go to work here and i was
doing other jobs and stuff but i always
found a way to get to class
and and then i was very fortunate to get
a part in a view from the bridge with
bobby duvall as the lead
and it was an arthur miller player great
arthur miller play
and uh and and i was very
celebrated in that part of rodolfo in a
view from the bridge
and uh i felt okay yeah
i i i can do dramatic acting i guess you
know
no more fooling around and uh and then
that
led finally to me getting midnight
calving because i met dustin hoffman
there
we became friends in a way and uh when
when i i read midnight cowboy
sent him the book uh i i was probably
one of
20 people who sent him the book because
the character was so
possible for him you know and his
work in the graduate his success his
celebrity
made it possible to make midnight cowboy
and eventually after
uh screen tests and stuff like that i
was able to get that role and that that
was the beginning
but and i i worked with or i
never one moment of it uh
was unappreciative of the break that i
had been given
and the wonderful circumstance of
working with these very very talented
people
and dustin of course was at the top of
the list too so actors prepare for parts
in different ways obviously
what's the way that you prepare for a
part you get a script you've decided you
want to do it now how do you prepare to
get in
i asked you ben i asked you the first
time
when i spoke to ben prior to just doing
this
i asked ben if he had a photographic
memory because
his his amazing
ben is amazing and when i uh we'll talk
about him later
but but but i asked him if he had a
photographic memory i don't
i don't have a photographic memory and
it's hard for me to learn
words uh easily
i have to get into the character somehow
i have to believe in it a little bit
you know and and i find that
going over the words and testing the
words and
improvising and playing that's how i
get to the part and it's a
if i had a photographic memory as many
do
i probably would miss out on a lot of
insights
on my way to performing the role so it
gives me time to
marinate and digest and and then produce
whatever i
have done how much of it is spontaneous
and how much of it is prepared i've
always wondered this
when you watch somebody on film well
it's all prepared
in some way but the but the real um
the really wonderful performance of the
great performances
in my estimation come from people who
are
have that danger they're doing it for
the first time in some way they're
improvising
something do you see so when i go on a
set
i try to say i have a little phrase that
i use actually
and i i'm just there
you know it's almost a challenge to see
if i'll do anything
what's the phrase no i can't tell
it's it it's just any way of just saying
i don't give a damn
so it's like you so i get up there and
then
it's all fresh every take i'm
looking for what's there and not
preparing to do it a certain way now
understand i've gone through many
many different uh thoughts about it and
and played with it many times before
so when i get up i have a i've tried a
lot of avenues so a lot of avenues are
open
i've closed off nothing finally when i
get to it but i
i know how this character speaks i know
what he feels about this particular
thing i know who i'm talking to if i'm
going to use
other people in my life and my own life
experiences and stuff like that
and many many techniques i think all of
them are worthwhile
but finally that that little edge that
you have when you
when you're really listening and really
at risk in the in the sequence
that's when the best acting comes so you
you're the parts you've played are
incredibly diverse and we've played
everything from hero to villain and
everything in between
so what are the favorite parts that you
played what's your favorite stuff
well i think that all the ones that are
are successful
are you know dear to me really uh
midnight cowboy that character and that
was that came a long way i mean that was
very very interesting i got that part
because i had an insight into that role
by the time
i did the screen test because i'd read
the book and i'd thought about it a lot
and i i got the role because i was
talking john's lesson she said oh john
you know well you're an interesting
young man and
i'll tell you what we're going to do
they had three people we have three
people we're quite interested in one of
them
i am and uh i'd like you to uh i'd like
to spend some time with our writer waldo
salt he's a lovely fellow
and you and if he thinks you're
interesting enough we'll give
we'll open up and make another birth in
the screen test
i said well i couldn't be happier you
know
and more grateful i'm i'm delighted i'll
meet waldo so
had pursued that character because i
knew
that if someone took that
that character and had any vanity
associated with the role
if they were wanted to be cool let's say
at that time you see this is at the end
of the 60s
he wanted to be attractive
to lose the part i said this fellow
is lonely he's
so insecure he doesn't know who he is
exactly and he's trying to find a place
for himself in society and he's trying
to
you know what people have told him about
him you know
a really good lover and you know all
that stuff he's trying to
that's the energy he's really at risk in
every scene
and that loneliness will provide a lot
of humor uh
uh and it will also touch your heart
that's what i said and they said and he
liked that idea he said that's exactly
right john
said waldo salt to me and so he
recommended that i do the screen test
and subsequently i i did it
and uh and then i'll tell you this
little thing
they were they had my screen test came
down to two people
one was eliminated right away the one
that was the front runner let's say
according to what they told me
and then it came down to myself and a
very good actor named michael sarazon
and michael had just gotten a big role
with
george c scott that was coming out
pretty soon
so he was more of the
they had more uh capital
in his corner and they were looking at
our screen tests back and forth and uh
and at one point uh dustin hoffman was
asked to
look at the screen test now dusty was a
fellow who i knew very well and
liked very much he saw me do that work
on view from the bridge
and uh and then he became a big success
with the graduate and i had not never
seen him act like we just came to help
out
the director on a view from the bridge
so
so anyway he saw the screen test
and uh apparently they asked him
dusty what do you think he said well
when i look at michael sarah's in screen
test
i'm looking at me when i look at john
voight's screen test i'm looking at john
and that and and i told dusty this to
check to see if it was real you know
because these stories everything gets
you know many stories get
shaped out of something like that and he
said
he said oh that's good
that's that's his response
whether he remembered it or not probably
didn't remember it
so so anyway that's how it happened for
me
you've worked with some of the biggest
actors in hollywood because you are one
of the biggest actors in hollywood so
who are your favorites to work with on a
personal level
well uh obviously uh the story with
dusty uh
he was a joy to work with we had a lot
of fun we improvised
all the time we improvised a lot of
stuff in the film we're on the same
level in some way we know how to feed
each other and that doesn't happen all
the time you know
chemistry you know you know you talk
about chemistry in our
business and it's a magical aspect does
it
do they have chemistry and i've been
very fortunate because i've had
chemistry with a lot of
a lot of wonderful people so if i go
through the list of the things that i've
done i have to say
thank god that actor was there you know
like burt reynolds
uh and deliverance or jane fonda coming
home
uh ricky schroeder
in uh in the champ and uh
eric roberts and runaway train those are
the early ones and then
later on uh i worked with with great
people
uh like shia labeouf and holes and uh
and uh j.lo and anaconda and stuff like
that you know
but everyone brings when they when
they're right for a role when someone's
right
they have a certain energy and if you
like if i was miscast
in a film i i could damage a film from
being
miscast i i sometimes my
ego tells me i can do almost anything
but
i can't i you know i'd be wrong for
certain things
so so you i'm very grateful for the
roles that i'm able to
deliver and very grateful for those
people who
come and and light it up so that i can
do good work
so how do you pick script i mean i i'm
sure you've been receiving
you know thousands of scripts a year for
every year of your career so
not not so much that but something has
to touch me in a script you know i have
to sense
a truth in it and i can be way off but
you know i i sense something i want to
say
in in a script there's to be something
and if it isn't there i
try to make it there because if
somebody's saying well you this love is
coming towards you you'd
take take the role and do what you can
with it to help them out and
do this piece and so i uh i have a
reputation of really taking a deep
interest
in in the script and uh and that's right
i do i want to i wanted to say something
that i can
uh live with do you have any uh near
misses things that you considered doing
no i don't know no everything was
perfect
i i i no i i
the ones that didn't work out so well i
don't really
they're like children you know you're
rooting for all the children
and you didn't quite make it or whatever
but uh not so many
you know i've done pretty well and the
ones that i was offered that i didn't do
i'll give you an example i say what what
would be
a part that you don't think you're quite
right for
they offered me love story and i said to
them when they offered it to me
i was you know one of the hot actors at
the time and
could get something done and ali mcgraw
was going to do
it and and i said no i can't take this
role i said
i'll ruin it i'll i'll make it too
complicated
i said what you want this is simple
all-american guy
really decent good guy and that's it you
know and somebody couldn't deliver that
and that's what happened they got a
great great actor to do that one
so let's turn to politics now in
politics in hollywood so you're
obviously one of the most outspoken
conservatives
in hollywood yes you've noticed that i
have i think you noticed that early on
yeah i know it took us it took us 20
minutes to get there but eventually i
came around
so so how did you first discover
number one that you even more
conservative because being in the arts
that's that's not a typical thing
yeah yeah well you know when i talked
about going to school
and with sandy meisner and learning to
act
it was the 60s the 60s was a
huge time great chaos
great disturbance uh
and what was going on at that time
was uh in many in many
parts caused by the death of john
kennedy i have been quoted as saying
that that america was traumatized by
that
and i believe we were in some way and uh
and there were there were forces at work
to try to bring down this country
internally
no one was alert to it
most people were not alert to it
and and i'm talking about i'm talking
about russia
cold war with russia well what did that
mean it was a war
and what was their uh
what were their tools what was their
weapon in that war
we had the atomic bomb you know
that gave people pause with us
and it's uh and we used it wisely
that energy to warn people off
but what we didn't see was the
techniques
that they employed to undermine our
country
to destabilize our country and
techniques it's
a list of things that they intended to
do and they had had practice because
they
certainly turned around eastern europe
north korea vietnam and eventually
south vietnam as well they had these
techniques that were at work cuba
and those same techniques were being
used employed here so
all of a sudden this chaos erupted and
all of a sudden all of this
came to the surface there was there were
people talking in the way they hadn't
talked about america
before and uh everything was negative
they had a list of negative things
america is this america's doing this
america's and uh these were planted
in in our in our society
and you know when you say make love not
war
right that was a plan from this
this uh worm that was plant was
put into our system there was the
frankfurt school that came
in you know you know all of this stuff
you're educated about it
and uh and i and most of people were
just saying well
it's easy to be critical of people once
you are critical
you know it sticks to you
in a certain way if i said well ben
shapiro is
he's an illegal maniac and you know what
i mean he's cheap too
boom somebody will hold on to that you
know
and that'll be your definition until
you're somehow proven wrong
do you see people like to know stuff you
know i mean
that's why so much of the television
today
it's critic everything's negative
negative negative because it sells in
some in some sense
anyway and this society that we have is
this
free society what an amazing thing
freedom freedom to speak now we're
having problems with that today
as we know in our schools and stuff
you're not allowed to say this and that
do you see i mean you're not allowed to
really express yourself
without endangering yourself
do you see and you know that very well
you know so uh
anyway that's what was happening at that
time in our society and we were unaware
of it
because of the freedoms that we offered
people who were enemies of our country
could
find a way to the media to hollywood
to our universities they could speak at
our universe
freedom and so we had um
people who were looking to uh to
undermine and destroy our
society that had a connection
to uh the young people
uh so what we have uh the 60s what is it
sex drugs and rock and roll how
wonderful that is huh
you're going to raise a kid on that and
that's what was going on
and and this was pl i say this was
planted the stuff was planted
so uh so it was a chaotic chaotic time
and i was just
i was pulled along with it they they had
marches
against the war right they focused on
the war this is a way we can do it
the war you know america is imperialist
who was imperialist communists were
trying to move into then take over that
country
and i came after i had some success
especially a lot of people were focused
on me they wanted to
john would you come and say a word or
this or meet so-and-so or whatever it is
and some of those characters were pretty
charismatic characters too
like abby hoffman for instance who i
knew
i was introduced to you know and abby
was a
very talented guy but he was drug-filled
and he was in the wrong he sat in the
wrong
frame but he was very charismatic nice
to be with interesting very bright
so he was a torpedo you know
anyway so i was caught up in that a
little bit
and uh and especially because of the
people the young people
in in this industry when i got there
were
all you know deeply on the left
and when i went on a march or so to
washington i went on one of the marches
to washington
against the war everyone knew that that
march
was organized by the american communist
party
i did and i didn't even think about it i
said oh well this is you know
they're good at organizing something
what you know i didn't
put things together and i think you know
and that's the way it is you know it's
uh
you you're not thinking in any depth
about these things
uh at least i wasn't i was what was my
focus i wanted to
get a job i wanted to work in hollywood
i wanted to be one of those guys that
was
you know the the continuance of
cary grant and gary cooper and those
guys
right that's what i was thinking and i
was very aware of the
world uh the world cinema and all of
that
and that was very romantic to me all of
it
but anyway i was not paying a whole lot
of attention to
what really was coming down and i didn't
have the tools to understand it
and then what happened to me
was end of the war when we pulled out of
vietnam
two and a half million people were
killed in laos cambodia
there now
there was so much bloodshed it was a
horror
there's people trying to cling to
helicopters to hold on to their lives
and uh and i saw that and i was shocked
you know because they showed me what
communism was
these people who were in desperate need
the people the boat people trying to
save their lives and their families and
that we had pulled out and we were the
only thing
holding that bloodshed
back that wall of terror
and i felt i felt that deeply and and i
also saw
most of the people who were my fellow
people on the left walk away from that
not even give it a second's thought
and that got to me that
disturbed me and i remember there was
joan baez had an
article in the paper took out one page
of the paper to say what was going on in
in these countries and how much uh
how much destruction and horror there
was for these people and
how no one was taking care no one cared
she was right and i identified with i
said that's me too
i i don't like this but it took me a
long while
because propaganda it's
scientifically developed
to infiltrate your psyche
and it's hard to get rid of it
negativity has a
has a special connection magnetism
you know if you as i said if you say
something negative
you know it has a draw that day that i
read that paper
and that day that i saw those statistics
wasn't the end of it for me
i tried to you know to see
where i'd gone wrong and little by
little
and with the help of many good people i
have to say
uh i came around to understanding
now what do i say about today to those
guys today in hollywood who were
just like me coming in naive
wanted their careers to you know they
want that
beautiful career they want that golden
statue they want
you know the celebrity that comes with
it they want the money and they're
getting
a lot of money because they're very
talented
you see do they what do i say to them
i say this is a serious time
fellas i say
pay attention find the truth
listen to the ones who are
doing the deep work like a ben shapiro
you know listen to these people
who are trying to warn you and are
trying to educate you and bring you
forth
our country is a special country very
special in the history of the world
when our forefathers came up with that
declaration of independence and those
wonderful words
it this was a shockwave throughout the
world
this changed the whole perspective of
leadership
and and and uh government
protect this country this is uh when
people say
from cuba if you want to know if you
guys want to know i say that to you
if you guys want to know what's going on
now
and what the stakes are talk to somebody
who's from cuba
from poland from these places where
where th this this
horror has been inserted into their
countries
talk to them they'll open your eyes to
what's going on it's the same thing
that's happening here the people from
cuba
heard the same words these people that
are talking
these people are marxists right now
these are marxists this is a marxist
movement guys
guys who black lives matter is a marxist
movement
they admit it the founders say we're
marxists we're
trained marxists and uh
these people who say they're uh
community organizers
they're agitators and they're trained
and they're clever
some of them very gifted people
know what's going on seek the truth
look at the facts look at the facts
while you're running around doing all
these other things it's easy to pay
attention to all the little things that
you
or what dress am i going to wear or what
so and so
maybe i should go on his show maybe it's
a
start looking at what's going on in our
country be responsible
this is your country be a citizen of
this country
be a responsible citizen know what's
going on
i'm going to ask you about the blow back
you've gotten in hollywood for all of
this because
hollywood conservatives don't exactly
have it easy in this particular town no
they don't
and so i'm going to ask you about that
in just one second first let's talk
about your internet safety and security
hackers are looking for your data big
tech they're looking for your data they
want to make money off of you
well why should they make money off of
you it's your data this is why i use
expressvpn to stay secure online
my own self it's hard to know whether
your device or network is vulnerable
if you ever use wi-fi at a hotel or a
shopping mall or anywhere else you're
sending data over an open network that
means no encryption at all
the best way to ensure all of your data
is encrypted can't be read
is to use expressvpn you just download
the expressvpn app on your computer or
your smartphone
you tap one button and now you have
secured 100 of your network data
and then you can use the internet the
way you normally would expressvpn it's
incredibly reliable it is the fastest
vpn service i've tried it won't slow
down your computer
they're rated the world's number one vpn
provider by review sites like techradar
and cnet you always want to protect
yourself from bad actors out there so
why exactly would you leave your data
vulnerable it makes no sense at all
that's why you should have expressvpn if
you want the best in
online security and privacy protection
head on over right now to expressvpn.com
ben for three extra months free with a
one year package protect your internet
today with the vpn i trust to keep my
own data safe go to expressvpn.com to
get started
all right so let's talk about your
experiences in hollywood as an out now
conservative
uh you know i wrote an entire book about
how difficult it is to be conservative
in hollywood i interviewed a bunch of
people in hollywood who basically
admitted to discriminating against
conservatives many top name actors and
directors and producers who said
that they literally would not hire
conservatives if they came across them
or that if their entire writing room was
staffed by
liberals that's just because the most
talented people of course are always are
always on the left
so what sort of treatment have you
gotten in hollywood now that you are so
overtly conservative and of course
pro-president trump as well
i i know that i don't get certain work
or attention because
of who i am and what i stand for uh
but um i
i think that it doesn't affect me at all
i mean because if you know
if you if you know something is right
you know
and especially i i'm going to say
especially this for me
to be on the right side to be for
something that's good like
let's just say to do something for other
people
if somebody said you you got to think of
yourself you can't do anything for other
people
i know that that's not the truth
you can't pull me away from that some
somebody no matter what they
slander they they level at me
i'm going to feel good about myself when
i help other people
and that's where i stand i feel good
about myself
so none of that really gets to me i know
that when this life ends
uh i want to be able to say i did the
best i could
with this life and in order to do that
my standards are
very high very high
when people say when they talk about a
great person
i heard this just yesterday
talk about the sculpture of a great
person
what is the most uh
important element of that description
what makes a great person and the
greatest
people the greatest people we're talking
about another level here we're talking
about
gravesville are humble talked about a
person who was humble
humility and how that emulator showed
itself
in in this life we were talking about
moses actually
right the most humble man who ever lived
someone said right
and that's the area i'm dealing with
i'm trying i'm competing on that level
so i want to be the best human being i
can be
uh and as i get older as the best
example because people are looking up to
you
what's your advice for for young actors
i get this question a lot because
you know i've written books about this
and because i hang out with a lot of
hollywood people you're a young actor
you're from
not la yeah you want to come out here
you want to be a star but you're
conservative
what do you do do you do you hide that
you sort of keep it under the i see
that's definitely
you or do you just kind of come out and
proud because and i'll be asked what
i've said is that everybody i know in
hollywood who's very prominent became
conservative
after they were they're very prominent
i've yet to meet somebody who was openly
conservative when they started in
hollywood
and then right now right now we have an
election coming up
right now stakes are very high
the country needs us now anybody who
understands
the value of this country and the battle
that's going on to bring it down
has to do whatever they can to
contribute
to this to donald trump's victory
and to our country being able to
revive renew itself
it's a tremendous moment in history and
i would say everybody should do
everything they can now does that mean
that uh i'm not trying to tell people
how to get a job
i'm not interested in that really at the
moment you know i'm saying do what you
can
and uh if you can get a a wonderful role
and be an influence to other people uh
that's a wonderful thing
and and and yet you can't
discard your integrity you know you have
to bring that along somehow you have to
care for your integrity as well
so there's there's many actors are very
very prominent actors now
who are quietly doing their thing
they're successful they don't have to
come out and speak like i do
i'm doing that for other people do you
know what i'm saying i'm kind of putting
myself up i've said just step back
fellas i'll take care of that
you know but everyone must do something
where do you think the future of the
industry is given how far left the
industry itself is moving we had this
announcement in the past few weeks that
the academy awards is now only going to
be
looking at staffing of particular films
certain percentages of black or gay or
hispanic or
women that the plot line has to revolve
around
one of these minority groups uh one of
these criteria has to be applied which
you know basically rules out nearly
every oscar winner between 1933 and
effectively 2007. so we've gotten off
off a little bit not a little bit we've
gotten off
and we think that we're doing something
these people think that they're doing
something
generous and kind
this racial disturbance that we're
looking at
was was created i i
you know if you look back at the we
mentioned the um
the frankfurt school some of the stuff
that they talked about gender stuff and
stuff like that there was it was
inserted into this society
to break the family to break the
churches
to just to destroy some of the fabric
that keeps our country together
and that's what you're participating in
people say what about black lives matter
john and i say well if you're teaching
children
that they are victims
i say it's child abuse
we have every child can do
their god's god's gift
make pave the way for them to be their
best selves
don't tell them that they're they can't
do this or can't do that
every child is a powerhouse spiritually
every every every human being
potentially is a power
a spiritual powerhouse so let them be
that
encourage that let them grow to their
full
height and and i think that races are
being used continuously
that's it one of the things that's uh
fascinating to watch is
the devolution of hollywood itself so it
used to be very centralized in la now
you do production everywhere
and uh because of digital streaming it's
not even as though there's a lot of
gatekeepers anymore so
are you hopeful that the kind of diffuse
nature of hollywood now that you can
produce a film in
the middle of nowhere with a small
budget now that this is going to break
up a lot of the hollywood monopoly and
allow
an opportunity for other kinds of
content to flourish i think that's
possible
yes i think you know you can make a film
with an iphone or something you know
i don't mean to just advertise iphones
photos but you know
they have this technology these days
everybody's got it you know every kid's
got it
so uh yes things are going to change but
there'll always be
artists that use this this painting
this paint you know in some way to to
give us something
and they have to be sound of mind and
heart that's what they have to be
so i i see myself i see
uh the hope is
where's the hope is it well i'm
as i've come along to understand myself
a little bit better
i've understood
the importance of god
and i'm a person who loves all people
of all faiths
and i say god is not sleeping
and i said this in israel one time i
said watch out
because melchizedek when he had the
writing on the wall
you know that was his doom
it was written on the wall god has a way
of helping the good you know
and now is the time when we need god
most and i think that something's hap
i think something is going to happen
here i think something is happening
with people uh righteous people are
coming to the fore
so many good righteous people we know
you know
even you know splendid people
of great courage of great intelligence
of great kindness and uh
and they're saying come along let's
let's come back together let's
let's pull ourselves back and uh and
heal that's what i say too so in a
second i want to ask you about your
really interesting relationship with
judaism because
yes you're not jewish we have a really
interesting relationship with with the
religion and with chabad yeah i'm going
to ask about that in just one second but
first
let's talk about life insurance are you
a responsible human being if you are a
responsible human being you need life
insurance i mean it is that simple if
you got people who are dependent on your
income
and then you should die well they are
not only going to miss you they are
going to miss the money that comes from
you but this is why you can get life
insurance you may be thinking can i get
life insurance right now
i mean there's a pandemic and there's
riots and the plagues and everything
else
yes you can still get life insurance and
you should right now you could save 1500
bucks or more a year by using policy
genius to compare life insurance
policies
when you're shopping for a policy that
could last for a decade or more the
savings really starts to add up
so what is policy genius i am glad you
asked it's an insurance marketplace
built and backed by a team of industry
experts here's how it works
one head to policygenius.com in minutes
you can work out how much coverage you
need compare quotes from top insurers
and find that best price
two you apply for your lowest price and
three the policy genius team handles all
the paperwork and the red tape
policy genius works for you they don't
work for the insurance companies so if
you hit any speed bumps
they take care of it they even have
policies that allow eligible customers
to skip that in-person medical exam
and do it over the phone which is super
convenient these days a policy genius
it's been helping out
my friend jeremy boring get his life
insurance so if you need life insurance
do like jeremy and head on over to
policygenius.com right now to get
started you could save 1500 bucks or
more a year by comparing quotes on their
marketplace
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it is nice and extremely important
to get it right let's talk about your
relationship with judaism you have this
really kind of fascinating relationship
with judaism you appear on the
telethon yeah a very warm relationship
with israel but you're not
jewish yourself so how did this go about
first of all i wanted to just just say
one thing i'm sitting here with ben
shapiro
i saw ben shapiro when he was a younger
fellow just out of school
and i immediately took to you i said oh
my gosh this is wonderful because i'm
always looking for the righteous
guys you know and i saw him and then i
saw
him i remember when you you took on ucla
when they were out of line when there
was some
anderson pbs stuff yeah the boycott
divestment center yes exactly
and you straighten them out with what
with what what was your weapon
intelligence that you were able to use
your information to glean this
information put it in the right order
and and put it on the table and back
everybody off with the truth
it was amazing amazing thing i think you
can get on youtube maybe you can get it
on
youtube i think go look at it it was an
amazing moment
and and then i saw you take on more and
more things as
you have grown and uh i just want to
uh say that
i saw you first
no but uh i i'm very grateful for that
and i and and there's so many people
and people that you've encouraged to put
the spotlight on
you know uh we have wonderful
you know warriors for the truth and good
now uh because of you and your
brothers and sisters who have come forth
so
thank god and you go into the you've
gone into these uh
areas of the universities we're going to
save those kids we've got to change this
we've got to save those kids because
where did the kgb focus
hollywood this is a big thing with
lennon films
the universities and now right down to
the
the kindergartens they're being given
the wrong information
you send your kid off to school and they
come back your enemy
very you know we need people to to be
able to
change that so that we children have a
chance
but anyway you guys going into the
universities
with the temper the way it is now and
they're going to throw stuff
at you and they're going to organize
these
primitive attacks you know and you go
and uh all you've got is you're in your
the righteous your your truths and
and this great gift that you have in law
enforcement
and law enforcement lots of law
enforcement yeah
but anyway but you're handling you
you're uh making statements because
those statements are getting
out not only from that auditorium but
they're
being carried around on youtube and
people are cherishing them and
learning from them so god bless well i
appreciate it's very sweet of you so
you've been doing the cloud telethon for
years and years and years yeah did you
get involved with khabad
what's your relationship you know is a
big deal to me uh
well who are the who is
a hasidic group and the this hasidic
lineage of jewish people
goes back to the 17th century or 16 or
18th centuries 18th century centrally
the balshem
and if you know anything about um the
history of the jews
the history of the jews is why am i so
taken with it
uh first of all my i had a very noble
father he was a golf professional
he had a wonderful sense of humor and a
great love for
storytelling and it was a tremendous
father
and loved his children told her stories
every night they say that stories help
you
you know when you're a child and i i
would have to say yes
and i remember my father would lie down
on
my bed we had a double decker bed with
three boys one year apart
and my older brother wes
was at the top and he's now called chief
because he wanted to be a
rock star it was named chip taylor but
he
used to be up there and i was down at
the bottom and my
other brother had his own bed because he
was the eldest barry
and my dad would lie down in either one
of these beds with one of us
every night rotating and he would tell
us stories
off the top of his head and they were
always so
wonderful stories and he had a great
voice and i would
just listen to the timber of his voice
and uh
be next to him and see his profile and
hear his words in this
room that was lighted from the crack in
the door where the kitchen light came
through
very romantic you know and uh anyway
uh he was a golf professional at a
german jewish country club
now what does that mean this is in the
i was born in 1938 so this is in the 40s
war years
but these jewish people
didn't have uh didn't have the ability
to have
a membership in other clubs they were
there was anti-semitism at that time
and what did they do did they organize
riots no they bought land
and built their own club and this
innovation was a benefit
of benefit to my family because my dad
put food on the table for us because of
this
and he was at this club he carried at
this club when he was eight years old
and he eventually became the
professional
they took care of my father uh they
encouraged him
they found him to be a good fellow who
was taking care of his family when he
was eight years old he was the he was
the breadwinner was eight years old as a
caddy
they were very poor and then uh they
encouraged him and
they made him one of the head one of the
professionals at 16 years old and at 18
they made him the head professional
and he was there until he passed and
and i felt the influence of these people
the jewish people in this club
all my life i think his storytelling
came from that
i think uh because he his his parents
his his father was a an immigrant from
czechoslovakia who never quite learned
english and so he couldn't have learned
from my dad so i
felt so much uh of my my
my dad's righteousness and
and kindness and all of this stuff and
and strength he was
he was tough when he saw things out of
line he was and he was always right
you know he would stand up so he he set
the
template for my life and that was
because of these members of the jewish
club
and i found out and then i saw many
things happen to me i remember
when people talked about anti-semitism i
knew what anti-semitism was because
i knew how crazy it was because these
people were so terrific they were great
people
and they were my dad's best friends and
they were very good to us
as a family to kids um
the three of us so anyway i knew the
falsehood
the the falsity from an early age and
i was angry about it too i mean at
different times i saw the
life magazine picture of a boy in
striped pajamas
behind barbed wire and i
and i felt at that time when i looked at
that picture i said this
this could be me you know and
so i had an empathy for uh
and an understanding of the of the
insanity of of anti-semitism
right from the go and for some reason
my friends right from grammar school on
up were all
jewish people i don't know as uh as
drawn to them
in some way and i was raised catholic
and i have great
regard for my catholic teaching i went
to good schools had good
good teachers who've helped me all the
way
uh and i have great love for
john paul ii who i played i thought it
was
by the way i thought it was fantastic
and then i
i met mother teresa i asked her for her
blessing
for stuff i was doing with the native
americans here
and uh and then i had people spiritual
people in the uh
in the in the native community who i
have
deep friendships with hopi indian man
thomas banyaka
great man anyway but
there was always this jewish presence
then i come out to california
and i uh i fell into a family
from the bronx very
beautiful family
and we became buddies and then i was uh
asked to go on this telethon i'd go on
the telethon
because i heard as a favor for somebody
who did me a favor who was a rabbi
and he said i write for the telethon
would you do come on the telethon
and i said well who are these people he
said it's chabad he said
uh they do a lot of good for people
regardless of race or creed
and uh and they're a lot of fun and we
have a telethon and this is how they
raise their money to
to go for the year i said uh-huh well
i'll check them out and if it turns out
to be right i'll be very glad to do it
so i go to meet the the head of the
uh the habadan california and
when they say these are they have
emissaries throughout the world there
are now
5 000 habad houses across the world
and when i get off a plane anywhere in
the world
i go and say you know the first thing i
asked is is there a haban house near
here because i feel like i have a kind
of a
familial connection you know but also
they're very helpful to anybody do you
know they
they help everybody and uh so i
i went to the telethon i met this fellow
and he was very remarkable this fellow
uh cunanan rabbi
and he's got these wonderful children
he's got uh 12 children i think
and i would i've said it nice
prepared some nice thing i've wrote it
down several times ripped it up said
well
maybe this maybe that a couple of
sentences is all you know
give to these people they help other
people you people helping people that's
what this is all about
reach in your pocket and give them what
you can you know it'll be well served
and then i hear and now the tote and
there's a telethon so they're going to
have
raising money and they're going to have
a tote and what is the tote they
put on the you know on the board how
much money they've made
so far they told them well you know 1
million 265 000
if they get up that far and i never knew
if those were real because
they try to do the best they can these
people are
they they live very simply they don't
there's
nothing there's nothing slick about this
group
it just uh they give what they have away
i know they literally just deploy people
to random areas of the globe and then
vera and then you're supposed to
come up with the donations a lot of time
just to sustain your family it's a very
simple lifestyle for sure
yeah absolutely but anyway uh
then they say the tote and then i hear
the music
and somebody pulls me into a circle of
scenic dancers and
my response was laughter i was laughing
i knew how silly i looked you know and i
had long blonde hair at that time you
know i mean i'm in the middle of these
days
and i like to dance so it's
but i was having a good time so so i
that's how i got into it
and uh and then i i've spent i spent a
lot of time with him and
the and the younger group his children
as they were growing they would we would
see each other
and they would always say john you'd
like this because they knew i was
interested in everything they would give
me information
about i played noah at one point and one
of the
chabad rebbies uh semicunan
one of the boys was going to school
there
you know and in australia
and he came by every once in a while
he'd give me some help and insights into
noah and and uh and he
and they would always include me and
everything do you see
so and i got to know the rituals the the
the different celebrations and stuff
i was very impressive with impressed
with the um
with the shape of of these rituals what
they the meaning the depth of meaning
and all of these rituals
so anyway i know quite a lot about
the the jewish story from these shabbat
people
and i really like hasidism i like that
baal shem the mad this magical figure
and all of these leaders are like that
the rebbies
are like that he set off he not only
taught
rabbis who were teachers he taught
leaders
and each of these rebbe's is a leader
and this le rebbi
this most recent rebbe that they've had
was this extraordinary genius
fellow who not only was a gene he was a
scientist
he was many many different areas he's
taught
he he he spoke 14 languages something
like that
and uh and when he spoke he spoke like
you he'd speak for an hour without a
pause
of all this information and people would
write down everything he said oh yeah
rabbi schneerson is
yeah something seminal figurine right
and not only all that
but he had this idea and this
vision of sending people all over the
world
populating the world with goodness and
light this is what it was this is the
mission of these people
and he sends them and now we have 5 000
you know and it's growing
and so anyway so i have a special
place in my heart for these people and
so much so that when my
partner my business partner stephen paul
from this little family
said john jltv when i want to do a
program for jltv what
what do you think we should do i said
why don't you do something on the chabad
it's a jewish life television right
i said why don't you do something so
people can
have an insight into what they know
because i i've been the beneficiary of
so much
mystical information stuff from the
kabbalah people talk about the kabbalah
they don't know what they're talking
about
the kabbalah is real rich in
understanding and all comes down to
behavior
so if if you can do a show like that so
that they
they're a lot of fun we they sing all
the time
i mean the valshamtov said to the people
who couldn't participate in the
the all this uh
rich legacy of of uh
the talmud and all of this he said i'll
give you a song
here you just learn this song and he'd
teach them these songs and these songs
are known today by these young rabbis
and they sing them and you're just right
back
you know all those many years ago and
so they're full of they're full of joy
and
full of wisdom in their teachings
and in their behavior and so
i said let's do that and so we have a
show now it's
going to open in a couple of days
on jltv and it's called friends of
chabad
and when my partner said to me he i said
you've got to meet these two guys you
meet the rabbi
rabbi levy these two of rabbi kuhn and
sons
kyun and his sons and you'll fall
in love with these guys
and sure enough they came and started
talking
and they and and he would ask these
basic questions because he's not
up on his judaism he's jewish but he's
not so up on it so he asked these simple
questions that
like the questions that a child is
supposed to ask
uh for passover you know what i mean
just the simple question
why do we do this why do we why do you
wear black and then
the answers he we got were so
extraordinary so i said that's the show
i said that's it
and said not only that but you have to
be on the show you have to be the host
of the show to my friend
who has a big personality wonderful
personality
uh and as uh just a radiant energy
so i said you got to be on the show if
i'm going to do it you got to be honest
so the two of us are at it with two
these two young rabbis who and and i
think it's going to be very special so
john i want to ask you one final
question about your favorite movies not
just the ones you start in just
your favorite movies generally but if
you want to hear jon voight's answers
you have to be a daily wire member head
on over to dailywire.com
click join at the top of the page you
can hear the rest of our conversation
there
well john thank you so much for stopping
by i really really appreciate it it's
been a real pleasure oh
for me ben very nice to see you you do
you've done very well my son
the ben shapiro show sunday special is
produced by mathis glover
executive producer jeremy boring our
technical director is austin stevens and
our assistant director is pavel wydowski
associate producer nick sheehan our
guests are booked by caitlin maynard
editing is by jim nicholl audio is mixed
by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by nika geneva title
graphics are by cynthia angulo the ben
shapiro show sunday special is a daily
wire production
copyright daily wire 2020